I know thank you for your question to
work with Wes Anderson is Alma
to answer question to work with Miss
Anderson is the greatest thing in the
world he is my best friend
we met on Rushmore and it's been the
greatest friendship I've known in my
life he's my friend my mentor my teacher
my brother my everything all mixed up
and it just keeps getting better and
better every every everyday that I know
is more interesting
I think that does max Fischer mostly and
then some of me and then it just goes
like that a little bit
there are so many great actors in the
world but off the bat I really love I
really love Jack Black and I would like
to do a movie with him one day I think
that he's super a supernova of talent
and untapped like there's so much so
much in there so I I would say Jack
Black
hi Eddie yeah I don't know about a
sequel to Rushmore Wes has never said
anything about it no every joked about
it but if you maybe perhaps hook
something up you know you never maybe
happen so but I don't know I'm just
happy with the one
one thing on my bucket list one thing on
my bucket list one thing on my bucket
list one thing on my bucket list cat
darn it I don't have a bucket list so to
speak maybe uh
the scuba diving
it's all about it lists all damn things
about it mercury